hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right today I'm going to be
covering movie news of the fourth week
of jun 2015 in three minutes or less a
member of the prop Department on x-men
apocalypse has revealed that Hugh
Jackman will indeed appear as Wolverine
Hugh Jackman will be huge jacking off to
that badass paycheck Star Trek may be
returning to television from the pitch
of a Trekkie fan in case you guys don't
know what a Trekkie fan is there an
obsessed Star Trek fan who jerks off to
asset Kira on pornhub com Dwayne Johnson
will be starring in the 80s arcade
adaptation of rampage no details have
been released yet but Dwayne Johnson
will most likely be playing a buff /
charming guy who we question is black or
not the CW is developing another
superhero show hot girl Hawkgirl is
being played by an actress so I believe
is black I would make a black joke but I
already made one for the last news
report I did a video discussing this
special announcement Tom Holland will be
the new spider-man John wats will be
directing the film Marvel did not make a
big announcement of this probably
because no one knows who the hell these
two people are the Fantastic Four could
meet the x-men on screen in 2018 nothing
official yet but in the comics the
crossover does lead to an orgy of
superheroes the graphic novel is called
x-men the Fantastic foursome see what I
did there Emma Watson will be
co-starring alongside Tom Hanks into
circle ki cigars didn't know I wanted to
bang Hermione when I was in seventh
grade director Seth Gordon leaves the
Uncharted adaptation the man who was set
to direct the action adventure
adaptation had previously directed
horrible bosses and identity thief so I
guess this is good news all right guys
let's it for my movie news today if you
do to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and Vine
trying to get product place owned by get
any more followers and you could catch
my videos on Latino Review com we run
like prison Mexicans and blacks do get
along on this website